Your book is so beautiful,
and I always want to ask when I see something so brilliant,
like "To The Last Bite"-
Sure.
What a rich concept.
Talk to me about what's behind it
and how this title was waiting for only you.
Totally, I mean, I think we're all
kind of collectively trying to be more conscious,
trying to be more eco-friendly and more sustainable,
and I think a lot of us don't really know what that means.
And I thought, growing up in the Catskills
and kind of in this kind of culture of reusing everything,
and then working in food media,
I had this, like, unique perspective
to put this cookbook together.
Well, this book is one of the sexiest,
most beautiful guides I've ever seen.
Really, I am so excited,
(audience applauding)
and I'm excited for what we are gonna make today.
Now, you're the driver.
Yes, yes.
I am your passenger.
I'm getting in your car.
I'm sitting down.
Welcome.
Take it away.
Okay.
So, today, we're making Eggplant Parm.
I love it because it's vegetarian, it feeds a crowd.
I mean, who doesn't love Eggplant Parm?
I mean, it's got all the good stuff, tons of cheese within.
Alright, how do I do this?
So, we've got the onions.
We've got the onions going for 30 minutes.
They're getting caramelized and browned,
and they just smell amazing.
We're gonna add the garlic,
you know, and we're just gonna stir that
for about 30 seconds until aromatic.
I'm gonna also say I love adding garlic later
so that it doesn't burn.
Exactly.
Is that why
this is happening?
That's exactly why
it's happening.
Okay, so now, garlic, we can smell it.
Add the tomato paste.
I have to say, if there's one condiment
you keep around in your pantry or fridge,
tomato paste.
Tomato paste.
I mean, you can do so much with that.
It's such a building block of flavor.
It's got that real umami,
and then you're just gonna give that a good stir.
Yeah, you can add the spices.
We've got red pepper flakes, salt and pepper,
and we're just gonna want to kind of cook that
until the tomato paste turns, like, brick red.
Okay, this looks amazing.
So, next, we're gonna add the tomatoes.
Okay, I'm pouring.
And you've got to be careful
that they don't spill.
But Lauren, our Culinary Director, gave me a hot tip,
which is if you, hold on, (banging spoon)
pour the tomato sauce onto the wooden spoon,
it stops the splatter.
Hey! (laughs)
(audience applauding)
So, once again,
thank you, St. Lauren.
Amazing,
so give that a good stir,
and we're just gonna let that simmer for 30 minutes.
Goodbye, sauce.
Okay, so we've got the eggplant,
and I like to salt my eggplant
and let it kind of sit for about an hour.
This, like, helps draw out the moisture
so you don't have, like, soggy eggplant.
You know, no one wants that.
Smart.
Okay, so now we're gonna-
'Cause it's true,
it's too soggy otherwise.
We're gonna take some salt, pepper to season the flour.
You can be really generous with this,
you know, this is just adding flavor.
I love this.
So, I'm just dredging it really lightly in flour first,
and then into the egg.
Ooh!
Flour,
then egg.
Flour, then egg,
thank you so much.
And is this a panko?
And then panko, and I like to use panko
rather than breadcrumbs.
You know, they're lighter.
Crunchy.
And they add like a crunchier exterior.
A few people have asked me if you could bake this,
and you totally can, but I think frying it
just, like, is better.
Yeah, let's get honest here.
Let's be honest.
Frying tastes better.
You could fry a shoe and I'd be into it.
(audience laughing loudly)
I would eat it, too.
But after you've (laughs),
after you've fried-
See, it's Claire
and Paul and eggplant.
I love life, I just wanna-
(audience applauding)
I wanna, I wanna get into it with all of it.
It's all the good things.
I'm a lot, I know.
No, you're perfect.
Okay, so once you've fried the eggplant,
it's gonna be golden brown, just like this,
and we're just gonna leave that there.
Yeah, it's not that brown.
We're gonna move on,
and if you wanna help me actually build this.
Yes, please!
So, first,
we're gonna layer the eggplant.
Layer the eggplant, one layer with some sauce on top.
Yes, and then some Parm.
Is what I'm seeing.
So, you're gonna use these.
Oh!
And just layer them up.
Oh, not cheese.
We're doing
a whole new layer.
Okay, a whole new layer.
And then, okay, I'll add the sauce,
and you, you know, how much sauce you like.
I mean, whatever you're doing,
and I see the onions, that's what I love.
Right?
It hasn't lost that.
It hasn't become so translucent and congealed.
So, now you're gonna add-
Parmesan?
Parmesan, and you can be pretty generous with that.
See, I've already spilled it out everywhere.
I'm messy.
And then, we're just gonna add the mozz on top,
and I like to just add them, like, full-on.
Like, it's just gonna be a full-on cheese situation here.
We're gonna pop this in the oven
at 400 degrees for-
Can you open
the oven for me?
Yeah.
Thank you.
55 minutes,
or until it gets, like, nice
and golden and bubbly.
What heat?
What temp?
400 degrees, 55 minutes.
400, 55, got it!
And then,
it comes out looking like that.
Oh, my God!
(audience laughing)
Movie magic.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I mean,
I'm gonna eat that,
and we have, like-
Oh, we, oh!
(chuckles) Of course, I'm like, let me get on in there!
You can have that one, but we have these, like,
little personal ones, too.
(audience laughing)
Alright, let's see, if we move the mess.
Wow!
We really have made a mess.
Wow! Okay. (laughs)
No, I did.
At least I own it.
Oh, okay, I know this is my own recipe,
but I'm so excited.
(audience laughing)
I know, I feel bad eating in front of people, I do.
Mm!
I mean, I'm excited,
and I'm gonna do it, but...
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
I know, I know.
Oh, my God, it's so good.
Can I say that?
It's so good.
It's so good!
And it's got
that breadiness that you want.
It's-
But not too much.
No, no, very light.
The eggplant is perfect.
It's not soggy, it's got a great texture.
I feel the seeds, but I like when I have, like,
a nice tear to the flesh.
(laughing) Yeah.
You heard me, I wanna tear the flesh.
(audience laughing)
Same, same.
I think we need to, like, finish these in private,
and maybe, like, that one too.
It's true, I eat like an alley cat.
I'm like, look away!
(audience laughing)
(hissing) I hiss, and I turn my back.
I'm not good at, like, public eating and dinner tables,
unless it's with my friends, but I'm like, I don't,
this is not the real me.
The real me motorboats food
and doesn't want anyone looking.
(audience laughing and applauding)
(upbeat music)